joining me now are two people who might
be able to give us some insights on that
jason stanley philosophy professor at
yale and author of how fascism works
the politics of us and them and ruth ben
giat history professor nyu
with an expertise in authoritarianism
her new book strongmen mussolini to the
present
is out now thank you both uh for joining
me you've spent the past few years both
of you
warning about growing authoritarianism
in the united states uh the threat to
democracy
how have the events of the past few days
changed
or confirmed your views ruth first
uh what's happening now is entirely
predictable
and i i hope that now uh people are
understanding that trump
was never in office to govern in a
traditional
uh presidential way he's never been
playing with a democratic playbook he's
always been following an authoritarian
playbook
and his goals for being in office are to
make money for the trump organization
build his personality cult and stay in
office as long as possible
jason so i think what we've learned
is the dangers dangerous aspects of the
republican party
a danger that will remain with the
country well after
trump leaves office the republican party
like like fascist parties
anti-democratic
parties regards the democrats its
opponents as completely illegitimate
uh they've shown that they have no
compunction here
uh they uh we they're they're hearkening
back
to what i regard as the the american
fascist structural roots
of uh a voter uh voter
disenfranchisement of minority
populations
uh and they're using trump's pop
popularity
to further their islamophobic white
nationalist
worst element
so i think you're right about the
republican party's kind of extreme
tendencies
uh there is in recent days recent hours
even
some republican push for a little bit on
trump i want you to listen to oklahoma
senator james lankford
saying the transition needs to begin
whether or not trump has accepted defeat
there's nothing wrong with vice
president biden
getting the briefings to be able to
prepare himself and so that he can be
ready the president's already getting
those
there's nothing wrong with the former
vice president getting those and if
that's not occurring by friday
i will step in as well and to be able to
push him to say this needs to occur
so that regardless of the outcome of the
election whichever way that it goes
people can be ready for that actual task
uh it's kind of tough talk even though
he's still not accepting the election
result
is it enough to stop the threat to
national security the threat to public
health
the threat to democracy that comes from
refusing this transition of power from
refusing to concede ruth
no and this was what a hedge regardless
of how the election goes and
you know i want to point out that these
people are living in
a fantasy world which is very dangerous
and they're waging psychological warfare
on the american people
when even a despot like erdogan in
turkey
is calling biden to accept the you know
to to congratulate him and here are the
republican party mike pompeo saying
there'll be a transition
yes but to a second trump administration
and then uh the government doing
things like you know they put out a
budget for february
2021 as though they're going to be in
office as though they
the election never happened and i i also
want to point out that
uh when people talk about trump as being
incompetent or weak or just lazy just
likes to golf
that's that's a little bit short-sighted
because he's been phenomenally
successful as jason also said in
domesticating the gop
to a point where they're going along
almost two
only three or four of them have
dissented and this is something
that's phenomenal it's phenomenal
success on his part
and and his use of what you call
psychological warfare is is very apt
jason let me ask you this
some people are still saying all the
fascism talk and you wrote a book on the
subject
is overheated brookings fellow shadi
hameed tweeted yesterday
i'm old enough to remember when coos
required extra legal action
i mean that's what makes them coups does
he have a point given that right now the
pushback from trump and co
is in the courts it's not on the streets
it's not via the military
i i don't think he has a point i i think
that
i think that we we stand a good chance
of holding back
any such coup because the election
morgans were large enough
uh that it would have to be a very
extreme situation but there's many days
left but uh what when democracies fall
they often fall by uh by the
institutions
by democracy itself by the institutions
uh
undermining democracy and uh and so
i don't think that's right at all you
appoint the loyalists
the loyalists do your bidding you create
a fake emergency
i mean let's remember that uh that trump
was going to
call up the insurrection act he brought
1 600
soldiers outside amassed 1600 soldiers
outside dc
for a black lives matter protest so uh
so
he's always waiting to turn uh to claim
a fake emergency
uh and call in a military
response now whether he'd be uh able to
do that
is another question that has to do with
our institutions but
no you can have a coup it didn't happen
i mean let me ask you this jason there's
a tendency jason
not to take trump as an authoritarian
seriously not to use
the f word in relation to trump because
people say he's not hitler
he's not mussolini but isn't that part
of the problem that we have in this
country such a narrow
and foreign conception of what fascism
is
an american fascist would be someone
who'd be
the most american as possible uh the
most american figure
possible i mean trump has been talking
about patriotic education
he's been drawing on white nationalist
military's allegiance to white supremacy
and essentially nazism
in the last few days uh there's no
question he's drawing on
what uh what tony morrison in her 1995
speech
racism and fascism labeled america's
tendency
to for fascist solutions to national
problems
we can't look at europe for what an
american fascist movement would look at
look like
we have to look at the forces the white
nationalist
forces the anti-immigrant forces that
affected
european fascism and they're going to
look their own cultural way they're not
going to we're not going to be wearing
lederhosen over here
yes fair point ruth the reality for me
and this is what i think about often is
that the trump administration the people
around trump would try and seize more
power if they could
and if they weren't so incompetent and
self-destructive and you mentioned a
moment ago they haven't been that
incompetent in the sense that they've
managed to domesticate the geo people
when it comes to running government they
clearly have been incompetent in terms
of
messaging for the wider public we've
seen in this recent election
they haven't succeeded so what happens
ruth when a more
savvier a more disciplined trump-like
figure comes along
that's what worries me 72 million people
still voted for this
authoritarian right now
so yes of course the argument's being
i've seen that argument recently that we
don't have to worry so much about trump
because he again he just golfs all the
time and someone really serious could
come in
and i really think that's not in our
best interest think that way right now
because we have someone who's been
extraordinarily successful
for one thing he's converted public
office of the president
into a machine to promote and make money
for trump
organization which is the height of
corruption he
until kovic shut down his grifting he
spent one out of every three days
at the at the trump uh properties not
just playing golf but visiting trump
properties
so again i would like people to see that
the aims of trump
as a president are not the normal uh
presidential aims he's not interested in
governing he's interested in making
money
building up his personality cult and
arranging things with lackeys and
flatterers and purging anyone who
questions him so that he can remain in
power as long as possible let me
let me jump in and do it slight pushback
it isn't the argument though
that look he could have won re-election
that's not scary he could have easily
won re-election
had the economy not been in the tank had
quarter of a million people not died on
his watch
had he just shut up on twitter for a
while and i just think that's what
people think they think if
somebody with trump's ethnonationalism
and authoritarianism and disdain for
democracy
and awful allies out in the white
nationalist movement
comes along but doesn't tweet like trump
does doesn't say crazy stuff like trump
does
doesn't turn a blind eye to a quarter of
a million people dying on his watch
that person could be a two-term
president yes
and here's the the one of the lessons
from this uh
looking back at authoritarian rulers and
by the way unfortunately for us
trump has the same temperament the same
character profile as all of them
even though the outcomes can be
different and they're highly
self-destructed
uh people and the way they structure
their government with these inner
sanctums
filled with flatterers and people who
allow them to believe their own
propaganda like is going on now
ultimately doesn't serve them well and
that's why they all end up rather badly
they either go into exile or they're
overthrown or they're forced out of
office because
in that sense you're right that they are
incompetent
um but on the way they do a lot of
damage and what i'm worried about
is that constitutionally men like trump
are unable to leave office it's a kind
of psychological annihilation for them
the idea to give up this power and so
they'd be all too happy to drag down the
edifice of
democracy with them
um jason one last question to you before
we run out of time
this is a global trend of course the
rise of the ethno-nationalist
pseudo-populist
authoritarian far right this may be the
first place in the west that it's really
been pushed back with this defeat of
trump
um how do americans though stop it from
succeeding in the long run
stop fascism or fascist ideology from
spreading in their society
apart from stopping being in denial
about it all right
so we have to stop being in denial about
it we have to recognize
that we have a native fascist
roots as nikhil pal singh calls them we
have
uh we have this with the white
nationalism that we're seeing
uh the the rallies that we're seeing
we're seeing we need a responsible
republican party that does not seek
allah gingrich to a one-party state
we need we need to address uh we need to
address
historical wrongs of racial injustice
because we get into this cycle
where immense racial injustice leads to
protests black political protests
which then a demagogue uses for as a
basis of a law and order
campaign and that needs to end and the
only way it can end
is by addressing the long-standing
racial injustices to which black
intellectuals
have long drawn our attention
well said professors jason stanley and
ruth bengier thank you so much for your
time